rice and beans are the staple diet of
the ninth brigade in dakuk
figures tony is among the fighters
he left his ex-wife and children in
sweden nine months ago
now he's fighting with the peshmerga he
says he receives room and board only
no pay food situation
for all of us here is like rice and
beans and the rice and beans are really
nice
but it's rice and beans and after weeks
and weeks and weeks
you lose weight but sometimes
oh yeah i lost like 15 kilos
it's a good if you want to go down a
little bit you know that's uh
that's good for you unfortunately the
muscle and everything of the rest of the
body
anyway so we got rice and beans is two
times a day
but as you can see over there the guys
is doing some omelette
and that's nice
the fighters come from sweden france the
u.s and other countries
they all have combat experience but few
are willing to discuss it
some have only traveled here on a
tourist visa others have kept their
activities a secret from their families
back home
heloisa a sharpshooter and paramedic
from brazil
is the only woman in the bunker she's
fought on a number of fronts already
she says she's found a new home in
kurdistan you are true thing
we get you some powder milk also to have
in the night
heloisa says she identifies fully with
the peshmerga's struggle
so we personally need support
international support from all the
corners
we together need to fight against
terrorism
don't see themselves as killers but as
soldiers
they admit there are some volunteers who
come for the adventure
but tony says the more people willing to
fight the so-called islamic state
or daesh the better it's really a
worldwide problem so and i think my
government is doing
too little and i think all the european
government can do
too little so that's why i joined
that's why i what you call it
decided to join the peshmerga because
peshmerga is the only one who holds
front against dash
the next morning they head out to the
front line they've had word of suspected
is movements
tony accompanies kurdish officers to get
a clearer picture of the situation
this time the scene is calm but tony
says everything could change tomorrow
he's convinced this war will last a long
time
and that's why he plans on staying here